hey there's alex mills he's the starting
pitcher for the cubs six and six with a
4.25 e-r-a for the right-hander indian
doubled homered and walked in the reds
much-needed win yesterday
and india sends that one past the diving
sergio alcantara
the table setter is on once more boy
once he starts to get on with regularity
again to start ball games everything
just seems to roll into place
one hop let's see if they can turn
and they turn it 643 mills uses contact
and gets the double play red starter
vladimir gutierrez and
chris this got to bring back warm
memories for vladimir gutierrez pitching
at the side of his major league debut
back on may the 28th
right-hander nods the sign hands up over
the head as he kicks and deals the pitch
hit well left field but there is schrock
fading back now actually come in a
couple of steps to make the catch ian
happ is one of the hottest hitters in
baseball of late
he's drilled right field way
[Applause]
almost
onto sheffield and we've been talking so
much about schwedell and wisdom and
ortega and their stories are great
stories but so is this one the
redemption the comeback
three and a half home runs now a three
consecutive ball game he's now just
three side of his career high of 24.
target way away
and he gets the call strike three
well that is a huge break for gutierrez
there that's a two-seam fastball and you
can see that ball started middle in our
middle away and then it runs off the
corner and gutierrez fire swing and a
miss took a little bit off he chased
that one down around the dirt strikeout
number four for vladimir gutierrez joey
botta one pitch he blasted a liner that
was caught by bodhi in the shift
[Music]
deep left center and gone
joey votto cranks a game tying homer and
the reds level it at one
that's his
324th
career homer tying him with the
legendary frank robinson
second most in reds history and he just
got a pitch that mills got up in the
zone and bottom takes it the other way
and that's a beautiful bit of hitting
you gotta love the way he stayed on that
pitch away just went with it and shot a
line drive out of here to left
and a one-two
good pitch a change-up and a swing and a
miss strikeout
for alec mills
he's liked his change up tonight
for good reasons from a number of really
good ones
that's that's a change up right over the
heart of the plate he really sells it
green arm speed
next pitch swing and a miss strike three
good good hook
from milsi in a nice inning by milsi as
he leaves the runner on
good job there leadoff man it's on and
now
a chance for mills to bun them up
[Music]
barnhart wants it down
of course you can move all the way out
to the mound if you're bailing while
you're trying to find it doesn't help
you a whole lot
six strikeouts
for gutierrez
nice pick mustacas second one former
double play
boy that's coming to the party isn't it
and it started with a good pick for the
backhand of mike moustakis
jonathan india singled to ignite the
game he is since struck out and bounced
to second
india
to deep center field off the ivy
sprinting up to second ortega's throw no
shot
and a double by the reds rookie
this is where india is looking out over
the plate he took the fastball in early
that's normally a pitch he crushes he
took that hanging breaking ball in early
and that's a pitch that he usually hits
hard and he finally got to his pitch and
he did damage with it
on the ground right side body gathers it
in throws him out inning over reds don't
score leave one we go to the bottom of
the eighth inning
free strike if you're right-handed
facing a lefty and you can execute that
pitch
nice pick by india
two down
[Applause]
three ground balls induced by sesa
opt them up
12 straight cubs retired and 17 of 18.
that is a major jam city right there
that is not a pitch he wanted to swing
at
here's the change up now
[Music]
ground ball
[Applause]
reds pitching
has retired 14 in a row
19 of 20.
so the land of the shields
out there at second
and that one hit in the air alcantara
[Applause]
that's
top ten tied at one de shields at second
he's the go ahead run poyer ready
and his swing and a miss struck him out
and contreras fires the first
and now the cubs will come up in the
bottom of the 10th and they'll have a
chance to win it
left field that's a base
jason hayward at the plate first and
third nobody out
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
loud ending to this one number eight
crushed by hayward
and the cubs win
401 drink it in